you're good together thank you
appreciate that good morning people
welcome oh what a mommy you're done
you're in stitches no you know no longer
in stitches that's right okay welcome
back knobby and look you're timely
welcome back to uh
I'll uh declare our meeting of the 27th
of September of the risk Assurance
committee
um open and um
I asked Ross why he's wearing a tie and
he said it was a recognition it was the
last thing I'm not getting any audio
sorry
sorry was a message from Alex to say she
wasn't getting any audio
I was only going to make the slight
guess that um
that's it can you hear me now Alex
excuse me
answers
we'll see what we can do
it okay perhaps I'll just keep going
it's largely the formalities of this
stage thank you all I was wanting to
thank you Ryan
[Laughter]
[Music]
well I was wanting to reflect was uh
Ross recognized the gravitas as our last
meeting for the uh the trianium and uh
um I've hit the Habit uh because I've
gone to a number of these in the course
the last two weeks I would like to
before we
uh get into the meeting and before we
even close off synopics I just would
like to clear thank you and the staff
for the course of the last trainium
um we do have a an agenda item later
looking at an assessment of the
committee
um and we will deal with that thoroughly
but I want to just recognize you and
your staff and the way in which they
have service the committee over the
course of the last three years
and my appreciation for what
um I think I could even say prefacing
that discussion we'll have later an
improving set of papers and actually
therefore what the committee can do in
the way of its work we still have
definitely some progress to make but
it's been great and I just wanted to
pass on my appreciation as chair for the
heart yards of you and your staff and
the the way in which we've been able to
conduct work here in the risk committees
so um I hope we're keen to continue that
in the neutronium but as I say with that
I have to say that with a with a risk of
having self-interest as far as that's
concerned but look thank you for that
and it's great to be here this morning
and we'll we will make it we will make a
uh um a start all the items are
important but I want to reflect that
when we get to PX is clearly a critical
piece and this is why the timing of this
meeting was now was to consider where we
are without our financials and again I
want to reflect that Patricia team have
done the Stella work to get us to a
certain position but we are Keen to
leave a a position that the new Council
on the neutrinium can pick up so that's
that's the key thing although as I say I
can't I can't dismiss that relationship
to say a health and safety paper or the
likes so that's all very important
so with that I'd like to make a start
please
um can I can I
um firstly just check we've got Alex on
Zoom do anybody else Melody
is Alex able to hear us now yes she is
great let's welcome it looks good that
you can be here uh India I don't think
we've got any apologies
um people keep asking me how long I'm
going to make this meeting for but I'll
try and make it before anybody else has
to go sorry Bruce I believe it's worship
for mayor all right apology
thank you
um so look I'll move from the chair that
we sustain uh sir Tim's apology to have
a second to please
thank you rangi I'll put the motion all
those in favor please say aye all right
those against
carried
um any matters of interest on the papers
coming up
imagine there is so that's great I
haven't been informed of anybody from
the public wishing to speak to us
um I'd like to move a motion
um
that we receive a major late item which
uh for those of you that have been
following your diligent box will realize
has been the insertion of the
2022
draft annual report
which is now in your books we need that
to be able to consider our item in
um in late
um sorry in PX so from the chair I'd
like to move that we receive this major
late Autumn thank you Darren any
discussion
there's been none I'll put the emotional
those in favor please say aye all right
those against is carried I'd also like
to move a minor late item and it's a
variable briefing that I've asked
um Patricia to give us around a matter
associated with rates and she's just
going to brief us on that in PX is what
I would like so it's a verbal item there
have been no papers or preset papers uh
the nature of the item is one for advice
before any paper could be prepared so I
will move that I may not a minor late
item in relationship to rates
um the uh tabled at our PX session do I
have a second to please thank you Bex
any discussion on the motion
I'll put it all those in favor please
say aye those against it's Kerry
there are no other changes as I have it
to the agenda or into or indeed their
timing sorry their their order
right
um uh if we can then move to the first
item please
sorry I was all um in the wrong area
Peter Well Done I knew you'd be up first
so if you could let off while I find
myself back to my uh
sorry thank you
so we've got the minutes of our meeting
on the 25th of August
I'll move from the chair let the minutes
are confirmed I have a second or thanks
for running all those in favor please
say aye
the motion is carried sorry I'm having a
bit of trouble with my system here
right thank you if we could move to the
I'll get there if we move to the health
and safety report Peter the longer you
introduce the quicker the more time I
have to get myself on the right right
agenda no seriously Could you um please
give us Salient points of your report
thank you
um apart from the recommendations I'd
just like to note the table at the top
of page 16 of your report and the
increase in reporting of no treatment
incidents and near Miss incidents
I'd actually take these as being a
positive that we're actually reporting
an increase of reporting and we're
making it easier to report incidents so
we connect on them so although it may
look like a bit of a negative I take it
as a positive change in our culture
through YouTube Peter I guess
anecdotally those incidents have been
happening all the times just people are
now realizing that they've got to report
them yes
thank you goodbye
thank you
um it's just really about the
terminology used and and I noticed a few
companies around town this near Miss
it's actually when they're looking at
accidents and stuff like that it's
actually not an EMS it's actually a near
hit it's it's actually you know the near
miss it actually is a mess that saved
them
um so I'm just wondering are we using
the right terminology with near misses
it just doesn't same as everyone else
yeah it just doesn't seem to make really
real sense to me
um about when you're talking about
accidents
uh well I I mean the near misses meant
to be what it is which is uh which is in
fact an Imus hello thank you go for it
I've got some some proper advice over
here sorry chair I'm happy just to
expand a little bit on that
um your the council is right in that
there there is definitely part of that
near-miss terminology that includes a
near hit
um but near misses are broader than that
um near misses are really those those
lead indicators of something that might
have just gone minorly wrong that tells
us that there could have been an
accident
um some of the examples that I've seen
of really good near-miss reporting are
as small as
um one of the crews went to drive out of
the lot and uh a broom has fallen off
the back of a truck really minor thing
but it just reminds the team around I
haven't checked that everything was
secured on my load before I left
um next time it could have been you know
quite a significant piece of plant or
something that wasn't secured and could
have fallen off and caused a major
accident so it is quite Broad in that
that near miss and we really do
encourage the teams to be reporting all
of those little things if we can manage
the little things then we really get
ahead of managing and stopping those big
things so in regards with worksafe who
are the people who police this stuff is
that the terminology they
absolutely right yeah okay I suppose if
if our policing people are using that
terminology then
I mean I would um it's probably Urban
Miss I'm passing on uh rangi but in one
of our committees we discuss what should
be you know is there is there a without
it sounding like there should be a ratio
is there a ratio between near-miss and
actual incidences
um and and looking at a work safe
program or a health and safety program
the answer is that ideally you would
have a good number of near misses but no
accidents
um and uh we talked about a ratio of 30
to one I that's that's the urban myth
part don't take that as gospel but I
think that's actually the reality of
actually what we are trying to encourage
is actually a
um a culture of concern for yourself
obviously but also your fellow worker
and consequently reporting of
near-misses tends to be a reasonable
sign of culture and a chances you've
said Erin to get on top of things so I
think we should be encouraging
um uh good reporting appropriate
reporting of near misses
um because it's indicative that people
have got the message
now the questions for Peter please
thanks Navi yeah just two two issues um
workstation New Zealand does use the
terminology near measures
but this this
column we got here seems to me to be out
of place
because normally when you look at stats
for health and safety you look at things
like accidents and they break them down
into the severity of accidents but they
also include incidences and near misses
and what we've got here is we've got a
set of pylons there that's talking about
the treatment or the the consequences
for the employee as opposed to what the
excellent actually was
for me that nemesh should be in another
cluster somewhere else which talks about
um
serious accidents moderate Excellence
mild accidents
goes on to things like um
right down to the very end to the near
misses that's normally the cluster
evidence
that what we've got there is actually
the the consequence I guess of the
incident or the MS
um
I think that's why look I um perhaps
Peter you can take that advice uh um
this looks like a relatively standard
set of categorizations snobby but but
Peter perhaps um on the face of the
Weaver of discussion around the
categorization you could just check what
is what is appropriate please
um
uh uh I mean I think this is one of the
reasons I was going to Comic knobby that
those first four columns are treated as
lag indicators they're obviously past
the events
um important though they are whereas the
near Miss tends to be treated as a lead
indicator
um that if you don't
get that room that falls off uh it could
be something more serious going going
forward so that's why they've had their
differences but I hear your point about
the treatment so Peter if I could ask
you as we keep going whether there was
any there's any refund to this reporting
otherwise you know it is what I think is
reasonably standard
any other points from Folk
I've got a couple of questions please
Peter and it might be as much to the
Senior Management that are in the room
I'm facing my depreciation that you guys
have all got out and and had a look
around
um I wonder if there's any broader
messages and perhaps I'm looking your
way clear or down down my right hand
side here broader messages that you're
taken out of
um getting out there and and doing
health and safety checks look I think
there are always three broader messages
that we get out of due diligence visits
the first is just that sense of
um understanding exactly how the
business is done by the people that are
doing it
um and they certainly appreciate our
inquiries our support and our greater
understanding we've seen some
improvements come as a result uh and I
think we've also had a good
understanding of some of their
challenges and health and safety issues
that they may be facing you'll see in my
in the visit that I made to Bluff
actually it was a reflection of what a
business what a cash business in Bluffs
and how unusual geographically it is
that if there was
an incident there so led me to have a
conversation with um head of police and
there's been a and of course there
wasn't really a relationship but it's
now been slightly formalized I think
that Steve gibbling's taken a real
interest in health and safety
and actually has been
um driving a bit more cheering the
corporate health and safety committee
and driving a bit more conversation
around all parties as to what we can
learn to contribute to health and safety
and what we learn from health and safety
for the rest of the business brilliant
well actually Claire you anticipated my
second question so Steve I'm looking
your way
um I was just wondering how these visits
were then you know in a sense being
passed on to the the health and safety
committee who you know after all our Le
groups so any comments you'd like to
make Steve I'd welcome those yeah thank
you Mr chair
um look in terms of the health and
safety committee uh there is a
relationship between the elt visits
we're also using the Skiller the
committee
um to do deep dives into some of our
critical risks that uh as an
organization we have identified and so
we have focused on loan worker policy
and driving in the last two months where
they've all sat around and really pulled
apart
uh the pre and post mitigation and are
we happy and then how are we within as a
system uh influence the changes at our
individual front line level uh so you
know for example when we get in the car
we know to do checks uh we we're
familiarize ourselves of the car before
we start driving rather than whilst
we're driving
um and and that's provide a greater
engagement with the health and safety
reps we've increased the number of
people around that table in the last two
months as well so we've got broader
representation not only at our front
line areas which are traditionally good
which is Parks and Recreation for
example as one example but we've also
got more representation from the cab
building
and just lifting that standard both in
terms of awareness and communication and
then making sure that there's alignment
at all levels of our organization great
thank you for that Steve that's um
helpful
members career I'd encourage you to
listen to these what I think are uh
growing understanding of the the
essentially health and safety system
because of our need as officers to be
aware of the system so Steve appreciate
that um a bit of our Comforts based on
your hard work so thank you for that and
thank you to the senior team for getting
out and uh looking there Peter the other
question I leave is my last one is um
thank you for including third-party
contractors again we're back to um
perhaps the the the the the the sort of
diagram we've discussed before but
interesting to read that was the
anything that you wanted to make or
comment preps you're in it could even be
you around our third party contractor
health and safety environment given
their combined pcbu for us
uh not for myself no Aaron is anything
that you wanted to wear at this stage
um thank you chair I think the key piece
for us is that uh we're we're on a
little bit of a journey in terms of
improving our health and safety as an
organization
um we're definitely at the point where I
think we are
um because getting better at our
oversight of our contractors and
therefore becoming more aware of things
as they are happening and that ability
to prevent you know get get hold of
something while it's minor and prevent a
major issue
um so to to the point that was made
earlier sometimes the reporting of
incidences is going up it's not
necessarily that the incidents are
occurring more often but that level of
PCB you oversight is actually improving
and we're able to manage those issues
more effectively great look and I said
that was my last question Peter but I
just I just wanted to ask
um uh that one so shall we say dumb
question sexually ignorance on my part
at the Clifton Wastewater part plant
what is a lockout tag
so a lockout is a I guess a key Industry
Safety process that is used where
basically you want to make sure that
while somebody's working on perhaps a
pump or an electrical system that
somebody doesn't come along and
accidentally turn it on and Crush
somebody's fingers in a pump
um so that that's the issue of making
sure that actually something is locked
out with a key and quite often multiple
keys will need to unlock that so you can
make sure that everybody has done the
work that they need to do before things
are turned back on brilliant I thought
that was thank you I thought that was it
but I'm glad you're confirmed yes
running it's just about Clarity with
health and safety here we are we are
talking about the health and safety of
our staff and the way they carry out
work is that right it's not our
facilities in relationship to public use
and health and safety of the public
username
um primarily it relates to health and
safety for our employees but it does
obviously also move over into the area
of Public Safety as well so places like
Splash Palace Etc in Queen's Park Etc
no this is something I yesterday when I
was walking in Queen's Park where we've
chopped down the trees in Calvert Street
and they've had access they've put done
light you know the big concrete a big
large chippy surface on the walk path
along the Kelvin Street side and you
just rolled your ankle easily as
anything on there it's suitable for
vehicles you know I can see while
they're using heavy vehicles but as a
walking path it is a nightmare and
that's currently in use it's not it used
to be ConEd off but that's currently an
access for people wearing all sorts of
shoes so I mean I I would have to raise
that as uh health and safety public
thing
right it's just yeah so yeah right
knobby just a couple of issues here um
ring is quite right because the public
stuff comes in under our pcbu
obligations so it's uh persons
conducting a business unit you can't
just look at your own staff you've got
to look at the people that are
legitimately using the servers that you
provide
um the other issue for me was the issue
of like it's great that the management
of doing what they're doing I mean not a
lot of organizations do that sort of
Deep dive stuff
um
but what I don't seem to get in these
reports is what's being raised by way of
routine stuff
um and I'm not saying that it should be
in every report but maybe we should have
a catch up somewhere along the line
because normally speaking you have sort
of different layers of dealing with
health and safety you do um obviously
the management go out and do their bit
um but there's also the health and
safety rep so doing their routine stuff
that might be weekly monthly whatever
um and then you do posts and stuff as
you have an excellent audio mission go
and look a bit closer so a good example
of that would be that if somebody was
routinely not wearing eyeglasses and had
an incident you'd go and dive in and
you'd find it people will get a bit
lacks on that so you do a bit more train
um but if they weren't wearing earmuffs
you don't get in a centaur an EMS you
just end up with long-term damage to
your hearing and so some of those stuff
so often missed in that middle bracket
and it would be interesting to know what
we're doing around some of that stuff
and maybe that's just an annual report
so you know what what are the health and
safety reps picking up are there Trends
and certain things
um well one of the biggest risks in this
building is the use of Technology
these screens
and the lighting that surrounds them but
that can often go missed while you're
dealing with other issue they just Nobby
thank you for that um and and it
probably Builds on a bit of my delight
in hearing from Steve and Peter perhaps
between you and Steve somewhere you
could consider I I think knobby's idea
is a good one or request is a good one I
don't want to make it formal at this
stage but certainly as a committee I'm
very concerned that that the um the the
health and safety committee feel they
have our support so one of the ways in
which we can show support to be
interested in what's coming up through
their work program in the way that
navi's signed at a high level so if I
could steep between you Steve and Peter
perhaps in the neutriniums think about
how we could do that uh that I would
appreciate that
yeah um thank you Mr chair like I think
uh we we are actually working towards a
new reporting structure through our reps
that which basically takes information
from our front line right through to the
health and safety corporate level
so we should be able to reflect that in
the next report brilliant thank you
Steve thank you Peter I would like to
move to the motion please which is that
we received the report we note the work
that's been done on site by senior
managers
and we note the summary of key
incidences and their findings following
an icam investigation I thought I have a
mover and a second to please thank you
thank you Darren I thought it was your
finger was up thank you I'll put the
motion all those in favor please say aye
those against
that's carried thank you Peter I think
you are still there for the internal
order and continuous Improvement mate
uh just a note for the internal order
continuous Improvement uh one item
that's not mentioned here Deloitte have
recently convinced that the rates review
so that'll be in a future report so
that's coming up I thought oh I sort of
thought I'd pick that one up I didn't
know they had preps was that that they
had commenced it which is great news
that's good
thank you Peter are the questions for
Peter on on this uh on his report
foreign
one question from me it's a bit of
clarity
um again probably a bit of ignorance
from my part um but would be Keen given
a matter we're going to consider him PX
um I notice environmental health
services and and including Ians
um do we do our own water testing or do
we send it to an external Laboratory uh
we do our own chip right so the irons
accreditation would come for for our
water laboratory would come into the
Environmental Health Services
um that was mainly the the food there's
many food Erin may have uh better
information than me on that one tip
thank you Aaron thank you chair
um out at our Clifton um treatment plant
we actually run our own laboratory which
does our testing for both our Wastewater
and our water supply Services
um to that point though with some
changes in the standards whilst um
tomato Roi is getting up and and running
um the team is working through uh what
we need to do to try and avoid um any
flags on our on our audit reports going
forward but yes definitely definitely
done in-house in a sense of the
accreditation though it's a it's a
accredited laboratory we've not had any
concerns with their accreditation thank
you Peter those those are um for both
environmental health citizen building
compliance I mean thank you for
characterizing them that most are low
but these are a couple of a couple of
moderate categories here you've got
reasonable comfort that all of the
outstanding or the open items are going
to be actively being worked on yes a
majority of the building service ones
have been closed since the report was
drafted
so the next update will um so a
significant change in those great this
week thank you members last chance here
snobby um just in relation to page 20 of
board books
um there's a set of issues being raised
by deloitte's at the very top of the
table
and just wonder why we've got some that
have not been responded to like
sensitive expenses got four issues
raised and one being closed are they are
they sort of work in progress and the
other issues a bit further down below
the the nice colored stuff going from
very high through to low there's a note
that says to date none of the
recommendations of tables one and two
which includes deloittees and of course
any inefficiencies or disruption to our
processes or services
so I'm not sure that quite means because
I mean I would have thought what
deloittees are raising are some risks
and so if they're raising risks
then if we haven't responded to them or
we don't have work in progress that's
close to being responded to or closed
off we still have the risk I like your
point good point Peter
um the first part Mr chair the sensitive
expenditure the three outstanding will
relate to a policy uh credit card policy
that's in draft and uh should be coming
through later on in the year
um the
note that I've added down the bottom
um is just that they're actually not
stopping us providing our services to
all processes to our ratepayers is the
main problem uh the main thing I wanted
to get across on that note that the
reviews and what they picked up
are not affecting their services that
we're providing to a community
I think navi's point though Peter is
um uh we might be providing those
services with some risk or at least the
lack of continuous Improvement and and I
guess it really becomes a question
is our existing service we need to
continually improve the question becomes
what's missing I think it's the point
that you're making knobby yeah I got
Michael first and then Steve well looks
of it thank you
through yourself chair just answering uh
councilor's question in relation to any
that will affect the service that we are
providing they would be deemed as being
high anyway so we treat them with
urgency obviously and resolution then we
work our way through from moderate down
to low in relation to the Deloitte items
I think from from memory all all seven
are currently in action so we are
actually working on all seven we just
haven't closed them off quite yet
um hopefully they will be closed off
within the next uh uh quarter so that's
kind of our focus is to keep them
tracked and keep them on on a focus
Point throughout each quarter to try and
close out whatever coming through in the
in the current audits
thank you Michael
brilliant no other questions or comments
can I move to the recommendation that we
received the report do I have a mover in
a second to please thank you rangi thank
you Nabi I'll put the motion all those
in favor please say aye okay those
against
scary thank you Peter appreciate your
your effort from work Matt thank you Mr
Speaker and yes I think you might be
hiding behind the pillar welcome Rihanna
um so I'll take this report as read it's
really an opportunity to
um update the committee on the process
for delivering the annual plan and the
stage that we're at in terms of
ensuring that our assumptions for the
annual plan reflect as far as possible
the economic environment so that you'll
see this committee already received
um I think at the last meeting the
report from infametrics and you'll see
in this report the process for updating
that and the key elements that we are
monitoring
um on a continuous basis inflation
interest rates and the rating base
growth and I'll just note there is an
error that the eagle-eyed amongst you
may have picked up where I have in the
dates listed them all as 2022 but they
are in fact some of those 2023
perhaps I probably owe you a chocolate
fish then Marianne and how's that so
thank you good questions for Anna please
you're snobby
um on page three of the reportable 23
board books
um I feel there's some comment to you
about Ty that if we're going to have
those commas here we need to have some
basis for having them there
um
so four argument's sake um it talks
about the transmission grid having a
capacity to take power north of
Ty was to close
um I've asked questions about this at uh
the Merrell Forum as well and while
transpair have done a um
a line upgrade right across the South
Island we don't have any increased
capacity to go across the street that's
about a 400 million dollar job
so I'm I'm not sure what that means
given that this is a an open document
um and the fact that Meridian are
quoting alternative industry users well
certainly they through the Merrell form
again have given us quite transparent
updates on that and they're quite clear
that
um the work they're doing in the
hydrogen space for example
um is complementary to Ty it's not at
the at the expense they're all and so
they've been quite clear about that
um they're not they're not moving away
from TY so I'm just a little bit nervous
about those statements I guess
thank you for that knobby
I'm wondering if you could just um
reflect on that from what Navi said on
the basis that uh that's come through
the Merrell form
um but I do hear it's relatively
publicly it's from infomatrix thank you
I think you are quoting informatics crew
yes so all of these statements are the
same as the advice that was received by
the committee last meeting
so they're they're not Council positions
they're positions that are being
reflected To Us by external parties
thank you
any other questions I've got to go just
I won't have one okay go for it and I
think
um I can't recall that coming through
Brad Olson but I think we should quote
him if that's the case because this is a
city council document it will be soon as
making a statement I think if you look
at page two at the top of the bullet
points it says for reference here are
the key points from the infometrics
report
go to if you go to page two and then the
following points which include the Ty
comments are clearly attributed back to
the stem statement which is infametrics
I think that's fine I think it's
sufficient
yeah just one cautionary thing about
interest rate predictions from whoever
the experts are that we that we do use
and quote I remember going back to 2000
14 or 15 we got given an interest rate
of 6.5 that our staff had to work with
and did all the calculations on and it
turned out to be interest rates went to
about two and a half percent
so and that that was a a bank here in
our favor but you know like it's just
I I really have to have some skepticism
about the accuracy of predictions just
purely because historically they have
been proven completely wrong you know
and I don't know you have to have them
you have to work with something but it's
just I just you know can think back to
that time where all our all our work and
everything was based around this much
higher interest rate
and then all of a sudden it was con you
know it was 180 degrees out you know so
are just yeah and I understand that they
are working on higher interest rates now
and the trend is that way but that was
that's the same as it was
seven years ago six years ago
I appreciate your point running because
actually that gets Us close to both what
we're going to be asked to resolve which
is the the number three we only have a
number one which is interesting
um um on on the uh on up here which is
to recognize the volatility of the
position that we're in which I think is
effectively the point that you're
recommending
what interests me Rhiannon is the
financial strategy that we're going to
adopt
which is clearly we're going to make
some assumptions at a set point of time
around interest rates around inflation
um and and our financial strategy
factors that effect goes above and
beyond what we plan we will make savings
so you can see in
it that we're using a number of
different mechanisms to attempt to deal
with the risk that councilor put on Joe
is absolutely right is there in terms of
predictions are never 100 accurate so we
are losing a number of inputs including
info metrics and the bill local
government cost index but also as the
report notes using this loan that we
have that is coming due and will be
reset as a real life indicator as well
so coming in towards the end of the year
we will make the assumptions and
continue to Just Adjust those and yes we
are preparing
um on the basis of cost management
looking at the fees and charges looking
also at the rating base forecast and
making that as accurate as we possibly
can as well as the inflation and
interest rates overviews
good at the current at the current
position
taking into account that volatility in
the suspension of savings we're
anticipating
that the annual plan was given its issue
quite rightly pointed out the third year
of the ltp will still be with some
reasonable bounds that we don't need to
consult that's what we're anticipating
at this point yeah but that may
obviously change when you have to make
their call we'll make that call at the
end of this calendar year listen to this
calendar year brilliant
um what's the size of the matures next
next year is it about 30 odd million
yeah
20 or 30 million 33 million is the
current liability by the way but that's
why I put 33 there yeah so it's going to
be it's going to be a size chunk of our
sizable chunk okay that's a very low
interest rate apparently yes which will
have a significant bearing on our cost
structures next year you're strongly
with just that comment of rhiannons
about not having to consult so are you
saying Rhiannon through tier that um
we'll be hitting
um a long-term year three Target of four
percent rates increase
no that's not what I'm saying I'm saying
that we anticipate being within the
remit of under the significance and
engagement policy not needing to consult
on the annual plan so that doesn't mean
exactly four percent there may be some
variation around that what is the
tolerance what's the plus or minus with
that not that it's going to be minus but
yeah I couldn't give you an exact figure
at this point but that would be
something that the next Council will be
needing to assess against an engagement
policy there must be a sort of a trigger
point that if we exceed our predicted
rate of increase that would it's not a
numerical trigger point no it's not no
so it's under the significance and
engagement policy it's the call of the
council for every issue to determine
whether or not consultation is required
all I'm indicating at this point is that
we're not expecting the variation to be
of a significant enough size to
um advise you guys to consult that may
well though change because of the
volatility of the economic environment
so this previous one we've gone through
that we did consider that there was
enough
um changes and discrepancy for us to do
that
the previous annual question yeah the
primary the primary difference was the
fact that you were undertaking an
entirely different options around the
museum that was what triggered
qualification last time around all right
that's fine thanks thank you everyone so
um thank you for the good clear
statements around judgment rangi and I
hear your point um Rhiannon even the
news today about a foreign currency
suggests that you know that the
volatility is significant so
um runny we shouldn't speculate on what
decision might have to be made towards
the end of the year all I hear is the
the runway at the moment is to not
consult but we're keeping it as an open
decision going forward okay any other
questions yes Navi
you listed three things that we might
need to look at in the uh Services as
one rates was the other
and I missed the third one
these and charges our fees and charges
uh through each year um
um sometimes we miss another option
there as well which is to cancel all
post contract uh projects going forward
that we've been using as a base of our
four percent prediction
because well you don't fund
projects are Outreach you certainly
service the detail rates so I guess
that's the fourth option that we may
need to may need to face as well there
you put it's a it's a lever as well
thank you
right thank you for that Ryan that's
very helpful
um and uh it's sobering
um might I say
um and I think it's fair even though we
will discuss the polling annual report
um and PX could add to that revaluation
of our assets and increasing
depreciation so there's going to be some
substantial challenges to the to the
year so we'll worry about sorry it feels
like I'm kicking it off but I mean
kicking it down the road but it will be
clearly a critical discussion in
December
um uh if not before as to where things
uh going so thank you for that thank you
renam I appreciate that can I move to
the resolutions which is that we
received the report and indeed a
critical point here we note the risks
that we've just been discussing
put the Mover in a second to please
thank you rangi thank you Bix I'll put
the motion all those in favor please say
aye those against it's Kerry thank you
very much Rihanna that's great
and I think you're still there for the
road map to Renewal strategic Projects
please
um so thank you chair you so this report
speaks
um specifically to the projects within
the roadmap to Renewal and some of the
other major strategic projects in the
infrastructure space that Council has
within its work program under the
current ltp
um so it's really to provide this
committee an overview for the key dates
around decision making and the
implications of any changed in structure
for the projects that are within the
roadmap
um obviously that at the time of the
adoption of the ltp that Auditors noted
that it was an ambitious program
but nevertheless the council when
adopting the OTP had a had a vision of
what it was wanting to achieve for the
city and presented that forward to the
community in its roadmap
so this report really is just an
opportunity for this committee to
reflect on
um the processes that the new Council
will need to balance up in terms of
considering how it continues to deliver
that roadmap and what the implications
may be of changing
um Direction
so
um my colleague Lee from the project
management office has really outlined
that it is when those projects move into
the construction phase that the
financial and legal costs become very
significant for Council of making major
changes to projects
um also there are strategic implications
for changing direction fundamentally in
terms of the sense of
um surety that the community has in
terms of the direction that council is
taking and the projects that it's
delivering for the community
so that is what this report is intended
to provide
thank you again it's a very helpful
report running
just looking at the
in the fine print which can be expanded
here in the chat just look at City
streetscape stage two now that wasn't in
the roadmap to Renewal but it has been
added yes and the previous annual plant
so
looking at that timeline phase complete
December 22. now where does with all
this project discussion and everything
where does council have the opportunity
uh to to look at these projects and say
hey
um we've got a
cut cloth and make it work when you know
that project timeline wise
um
so in terms of the long-term planning
process
um as the plan exists at the moment
which you may recall was presented to
the last risk and Assurance committee
the intention is that the new Council
will have the opportunity in November to
really discuss in detail at strategic
priorities whether it believes that the
Strategic challenges facing the city
have changed
um and thinking about those within the
context of the well-being outcomes that
it wants to achieve for the city and
then in December in the intention is for
the annual plan if you refer back to the
previous report to be able to discuss in
detail what the
um updated assumptions for the economic
environment might mean and then consider
all of council's work program including
its strategic projects in terms of the
levels of service that it wants to
provide to the community so really
November and December this calendar year
is the opportunity to discuss those
and make decisions
if that is what the council wants us to
do no that's cool no no appreciate that
thank you thanks for any other questions
or comments please yes knobby uh two
really in relation to two projects
um
on the uh dashboard it says for the
storage
um stage for the museum
it says in the fine print there project
fully committed with regard to
Construction
now I asked at the last
um
meeting we had at this committee back on
the 21st of August what that actually
meant and I got an assurance from
management that nothing would be
physically done
in relation to that site until November
which ties on what Rihanna just said and
I also asked do we have an exit cause
and the answer was we have exit Clauses
on all contracts so I just want to make
sure what that actually means that we
have not started that project yet it's
from a construction procedure because
the advice we've been given earlier in
this document is excellent it talks
about the 80 20 principle you don't
don't wait till you're halfway through
construction before you start pumping
the pen because it creates all kinds of
issues but I just want to have some
assurance that we haven't started only
down there my way of construction
Aaron has hit something you could help
us with please
thank you chair
um it would probably be helpful for us
to have had an Asterix on this one so I
apologize
um what's that's reflecting is that the
the project you're you're right the
counselor is right isn't actually into
physical construction yet
um but elected members may recall that
this the contract formation for this
project is slightly different where it
is a design and build contract which
means although there is a pause point to
come back at the end of the design phase
it is a I guess a heftier contract that
is already in place for for that
construction period so is a more
difficult one to get out of given that
we have already committed to the
Construction contract
but construction has not actually
commenced
you're snowing yeah so I think I read in
the document somewhere that um where the
60 or 80 design phase
one of the game some clarification that
while we might have a joint
um
design and build contract we haven't got
to the build stage yet
correct okay and the other issues in
relation to the cab
um Redevelopment or
refrigeration and the figures in this
report don't stack up with the figures
in the last report on the 25th of August
25th of August one it said
um the project was initially
um earmarked at 16 million dollars in
fact prior to that was actually 14. the
ETC which is the estimate to complete
was 26 million
and so that was what was the last last
meeting in late August and this one
we've got a budget that says 16 million
so that's the same as the previous
report and then the ETC which is the
estimate to complete is 1.7
and uncommitted as 14.28 and those
figures just don't add up compared to
the last report so I just want to know
that whether there's been a clawback on
the cost there or some redesign of what
we're going to do
and again at the last meeting I've got
insurance from staff that in the 2023
Financial year only 600 000 would be
committed to this project and the
remaining amount which is
um best part of 24 point something
million was in the following two years
and I just want to make sure that that's
still the case
you don't need a position to help please
I just need to go take away and check
those numbers with regard to the
previous report and report back to the
committee thank you that would be great
I'd be grateful if you could do that
that's a response coming back Navi any
other points questions just those two
issues thank you
um Rhiannon one of the things um and it
may be perhaps
um for future report and I was very
grateful for the analysis of the risks
um but the the seed here generically as
far as I can see do you have any sense
of where I would rate those risks at
this stage it probably needs to be it
could either be overall and that might
be as much about the pmo but it might
also be on a project by project basis I
was just wondering if you give
characterize for me any of the the sort
of status of those risks
foreign
well I know that those risks are
characterized within the corporate risk
schedule
um but I'm apologies to I couldn't tell
you at this point
I suspect that that's fine and no no
drama it's not um I'm not being critical
I just would like to reflect
um going forward I would be interested
to get a level of characterization
please then of as I call it off that of
those risks because they are they're
probably the real thing that we as a
committee should be worried about you're
quite right about a corporate risk
register but we we don't see that so
Michael are you going to correct me or
or help no throw yourself to you
um the risks that are included in this
report are designed around the roadmap
for the renewal so it's about delivery
of the roadmap not about the individual
projects the individual projects we come
back with a pmo report that we present
to um this committee on a cyclical basis
and that's got the risks Associated
teach individual project in it so at the
more granular level
um this one was more focused about what
are we doing around the renewals program
as a total about the road map to Renewal
and so Myra so that really was the first
way I talked about my question Michael
was what's what helps the nature what's
the relative status of these risks to
the overall program
I'm interested in that going forward if
that's possible we connect that in like
that's not that's because I'm sure your
your committee's all over the individual
project by project which is still
valuable to see I wouldn't want that
taken out but I would like to see it
within the context of our annual program
yes Frankie I would say from a
governance point of view come November
that Council does sit down and have a
really open book look a really clinical
look at the way forward seriously it's
that's I see that as the risk is
November where the decisions are made
the information provided the you know
the financials provided
because really what we decided in
November we need to commit to but that
that's going to be a lot of work
involved I I just feel that at the
moment I'm very very weary of where we
are currently but knowing that November
is an opportunity to have another look
at it then that gives me confidence but
that that would be our
that's a very important time I I don't
know can I ask Mr Dave if that's if he
thinks that's relative
foreign
that I would say it's clear from
rhiannon's prior paper
that that obviously as we go into the
annual plan and dare I say not too far
away going into the next ltp
um while this is a really important
program we've started we've got to
consider in light of of the financial
position and and project the position
going forward so I suspect it will have
to be in some form I don't know the date
but some form of serious thing Michael
if you've got a point you like to back
there uh no just throw yourself chair
was just going to actually make the same
comments it is through the um annual
plan process that will be at around that
same timeline that you're talking about
Council thank you thanks Navi you had a
question yeah just two follow-up
questions I guess uh Aaron just stated
that um I will need to come back to you
when's the comeback
is it today I'm sure it'll be as soon as
possible
um
what I'm concerned about is we're
running out of meeting space
no secret that
some people around this table are loving
for a pause on that on that on that um
Museum Store it's an online I guess so
when we when we hear the November review
of projects I don't want that museum
project to be too far down the track
that we can't excise our rights to to
pause it
the Museum's storage project was not a
project on which Aaron undertook to come
back to you there was a memo that was
distributed to your wall uh the week
before last while I was away that gave
an absolute update on exactly where that
is at and
um it was explained and it remains
correct that there is a 100 design
portion at which there is a pause for
Council to make a deliberate decision
Aaron undertook to come back to in
relation to the cab and my
interpretation of that was that that
would be by memorandum
um because it would be something that
would be in writing and that will be
done before the end of the term
foreign
any other questions I would like to
raise please
um just um uh as
um I go into this I just would like to
note three there which is an important
one that's why I've come back to the
risk issue by the way so Michael I
appreciate this about the total project
the way we make our decisions going
forward are important from that third
one we haven't discussed much which is
our reputational risks that's why I
liked the characterization of the risks
at that high level you know do we have
the right information
Etc becomes really really important so
I'll be very keen to see how that one
goes look I'd like to go to the the
recommendations if I could please that
we receive we note the project manager
officer roadmap renewal blah blah update
and we note the Strategic financial and
reputational risk so I'll move that from
the chair to I have a second to please
thank you Darren any discussion on the
motion
I'll put it then all those in favor
please say aye those against
Carrie thank you around and appreciate
your time
right Financial risks it's all about
they are weird I suppose that's fair
enough for a risk and Assurance
committee Patricia in your hands okay so
um
really the sensitive expenditure which
didn't come to the last month's um
meeting because we tried to tie as much
of the trianium into the last quarter so
that's the sensitive expenditure listing
from 1 April to 9th of September
as well as um we have also included the
knit deep movements across each of the
net did accounts or the financial year
um it does include things like the
animal control fund which was discussed
at PPP
um last week
um but it does show how that movement so
we've had a 14.9 million increase in any
debt position so if debt has increased
by 14.9
and that's made up of a number of
different moving Parts within there
the current Surplus which is
predominantly from Capital subsidies
adjustments for depreciation a capital
expenditure
the sale of assets and a drawdown of our
loan to ICL which gives that 14.9
million
I'll take any questions from anyone
right thank you for that are there any
um I think um it would be good to take
this as two items one is to firstly just
he just quickly have a chance for
members to comment on the center of
expansion then we'll revert back to the
net debt
balances and also the over you're sorry
The Net debt account balances are there
any questions around since all points
around sensitive spinach if you like to
make Darren thanks chair can I just
check that the
um airfares next to my name for lgnz
were recovered
because the flights were canceled I will
double check but we tend to find the
credits come much later than the debits
hit
[Laughter]
very interesting experienced traveler I
can I can support that view actually
Patricia thanks for that question
um
Leslie
and I'm a little bit surprised at that
um I think it's just when everyone's
costs came through like the next page
has got the LG NZ conference under me as
well in the right month the March 22 is
just a bit of a surprise okay I will
double check it but
yeah that you'll see on the next page
it's listed on June 22 which is
legitimately of course
correct but the March 22
yeah
you're right and down below
um you've got course fees one two four
nine yeah 22 which
seems very very young
the rest you're a sucker for punishment
to go to the conference videos
thank you Lucy and appreciate that that
is important to get it um particularly
for this report to get accurate so
um if we could just uh um ask Patricia
that you update the record so that quite
reasonably uh Leslie it's only there for
the one time any other comments that
people like to make about sensitive
expenditure
Bubsy reflects conference season dare I
say it in some important other matters
going on around
that where people have been on the road
in particular for Council so it looked
reasonable to me any other questions
there'd be none can we go to the net
debt account please
um and and check are there any questions
about this in Patricia I certainly uh Mr
B you said there's already been some
explanation of at least one of these
accounts so there was a paper on the
animal controller right okay so are
there any other comments or questions
people would like to raise over addicted
again yes snobby
um just probably a wider one that we've
discussed before which is around
um
and net debt limits on whether going
forward will breach the the limit of 150
percent and we've had reports to say
that we will for a short period of time
and it was interesting to listen to the
commentary about Auckland City this
morning on TV
they've got a double a rating which is
one one slot below us and we double A
Plus
the the account debt level against nzfa
um criteria is 290 the limit being 300
and it was interesting that one of the
candidates said
um your rating is not about how well you
manage your budget it's just your
ability to pay and given that councils
have an ability to put up rates to any
limit they're there
um brave enough to do that's what drives
the financial rating I thought that was
interesting because we've we've
sometimes
got a little bit conservative about that
150 percent and it was set at a time
when the maximum was 200 the maximum is
actually 300 now so whether we need to
answer that someone online is for maybe
for the next Council
um and I'm not suggesting we get into
further deer not red at all there's time
to be prudent but just thought that that
issue's come up again I think
thank you um
um that is one of the the issues that
will new Council will have to look at
around both the annual plan and for
annual plan and long-term plan sure as
we re-look at the financial strategy
it's a very very good point knobby and
indeed at CBD to pay I mean when you
look at uh um
clearly the key number is the headline
of of what you said yourself and you
said it's 150
um you also gotta and I think you
already referred to in a previous but
stability of the rate per the rate payer
to be the interest costs to go with it
so there's generally well there is
actually this will again get to with the
annual report a um a requirement for it
to be less than 10
um of your total revenue so um there are
there are other Prudential limits that
you should take into account when you're
considering net debt uh if I could just
make a combat Auckland which I have an
interest in especially with a growth
Council
um and and indeed they're one of the
councils that under our GFA rules can go
to 300 but it's a sinking bid policy
that got reduced by five percent over
the next couple of years so um there is
some credential discipline there on the
growth Council as well they need to go
to that limit just to try I mean I think
they're just great it's fair to say that
we've been conservative in the past and
and with conservatism sometimes you
don't have the facilities that you might
you'd like to see in your community but
when we get to what we're at at the
moment financially we're actually in a
much better position for our community
and you can just compare us with the
need and there's two two good examples
that's a good point Navi and and
Patricia is quite right that as you put
everything into the Melting Pot for the
annual plan your funding and financing
policies employee didn't become
beginners one of those centerpieces of
the decision you've got to make now I
had a couple of hands somebody was at
you Darren yes and then I've got rungy I
think no no thanks to you um my comment
was really that
um once we get some clarity around asset
ownership as well that's the other part
of that equation that we'll need to take
into account when looking at that review
of the debt strategy yes thank you
for any other questions hope block race
between none can I move to the
recommendations please that we receive
the report
we receive uh in accordance
um with the sensitive sensitive
expenditure policy the sensitive
expenditure listing I think just for the
benefit of these things we should note
with minor Corrections
to be added if I could just leave it at
that please because I think it's
important given the nature of this
report
and we approve the 14.9 million dollar
increase in the net paid account
balances
can just check before I ask for a mover
and a secretary can we approve
because it was in my room but I haven't
got I mean to go back to my terms of
references to whether I could approve a
net balance I don't know whether I can
sorry I am characterizing that as the
committee sorry
I think we need to note I I would be
more comfortable with I think approving
would be a matter for Council and
council with its uh with its Financial
strategy head on board so to that degree
Mr chair it'd be wise for you too and
you note that and recommend to council
yes I think that's a fair point I'm
happy for that thank you for the uh Sage
advice
well I've seen I've put that slight
change here I'll move these motions
please do I have a signal
thank you rangi there's any discussion
on the motions
we've got an audio I've just gone
straight to reword it rather than look
for an amendment but we'll do it that
way
those against
Kerry thank you very much appreciate
that
thank you for that Patricia that's um
that's that's very helpful
right now um I guess probably I should
speak to this um if if that's okay
um although Michael is anything that you
would want to add at the start or or um
you help me Orient and actually around
and help me with this at the start has
anybody comment stuff you'd like to make
before I put a couple of my chair colors
on top of this one
no no okay sweet look thank you um this
was really um I was about to say my
initiative therefore I'm going to take
responsibility if for those of you that
didn't want to fill this in can I
firstly say thank you to the other seven
that I was the eighth
um so my appreciation and
um that's also a start because I
understand there would be some staff
amongst it as well I want to reflect
that it is important that we do
something of a check of our performance
um and it's done in different ways
around the different committees I'm on
but I tend to like this to achieve a
baseline And I think it has actually
um brought out some useful points
to take forward with the new Council
um and
um I just want to reflect though that
um my opening comments said uh my
appreciation to staff because I think
you've allowed us to develop the nature
of the committee's work
I know there's challenges around this
scope of the committee's work but that
might be a debating point which I'm
happy to hear from this meet in this
course of this but we on a development
Journey terrible phrase but I'm going to
use it thank you that you guys have come
with us on that we've got a way to go
um and I would want to say the glaring
hole for this committee is a proper
quarterly risk report
and I know that that's being progressed
but I don't want to reflect that we are
at a good level but we need to do better
in my view
um I think that's just a couple of other
points I'd like to note firstly there's
also a time to review the terms of
reference
and actually my view the agenda of the
committee what do we do and I've had
perhaps that the humerus end of the
scale
um some questioned about the time we
take with this meeting so it does say
what is the agenda what do we do that
would be reasonably important and I also
note the importance of induction uh
coming up with the new trinium and
actually what does this committee do and
how do the other members of the of the
the council relate to the work
of the committee so with those comments
I'm very grateful random that you ran
this for me please and we've got the
results here I would open up for members
comments or um
uh questions in fact if I can invite
Senior Management to hear any questions
or points you'd like to make I'm very
open to hearing those as well because I
did ask you guys to be part of the part
of the review clear so if there's any
comments please raise
silence
yes Lobby and that opens it up for my
term
um a couple of Reflections I guess Bruce
um this committee has grown
significantly in its work
and I wonder when we look to the terms
of reference next time it seems to me if
you want to put a lens across everything
we're doing Council there's always a
risk every piece of work is going to
risk to it and I just wonder whether we
need a bar over which stuff comes to
this committee otherwise this Committee
just gets bigger and bigger and longer
and longer and the time's not the issue
for me it's just that we just it seems
to me that we put
um
put papers in some cases to the to the
two chairs Darren and rang it and then
it comes here as well and I wonder where
there's some way of having a division on
that so if either the chairs got a piece
of work that what they'd refer on here
is just the risk component not the whole
paper it just seems that in some cases
we actually go through a committee to
here and into full Council which we've
got today and just seems with triple
double and triple dipping and I'm not
sure where we get Advantage out of that
um the other issue for me is um I'd like
some breakdown of who completed the
survey I don't want names that's totally
inappropriate but it said unto me that
we've um got a potential group of people
who should be filling in the survey that
you and Rihanna did and by my assessment
if you include monofinoid it's 22 and
we've got eight replies and so I'd like
I'd like to know what the breakdown was
for our elected group because I think
that's a dismal result and that's no
reflection on you or Rihanna I just
think it's tonight's five governance and
three management [ __ ] up okay page 43.
it really need needed to be more than it
I mean we've had an example of that in
the past which I won't go into but
that's not helpful when important issues
like this the future of this committee
and what it does has such a poor
attendance
that's partly why as king Nabi to have
the uh to have start start this as a
process assuming the committee continues
because it is important that we look at
our Effectiveness yeah can I can I
comment on your
um uh just on the the agenda and I agree
I'll be honest with you we're a bit
hamstrung because we don't have a proper
quarterly risk of reporting at this
stage and I don't I don't I described it
as fact not as a as a qualitative
statement I think once we start that
maybe it will better in my experience
characterize what is the genuine work of
the committee I think it has been pretty
genuine but if I was to go back to the
um
uh the pmo project one you can see my I
think the valid interest yep on any form
form of sort of high risk perspective of
this council is our capacity to
undertake our Capital program yeah I'll
be honest with you now I would say just
about every committee certainly that I'm
on but certainly every Council will have
Capital program delivery as it's as a
major risk that's why I wanted to focus
on the the four wallet pointed risks or
five whatever number it was that's the
primary area the the project by project
is of interest but that's why I said
runy I presume you guys deal with this
on a detailed basis in whatever way you
choose to in the course of your
committee so
um I'm agreeing with your point but I'm
saying we don't have the mechanism to
really craft that until we get on top of
the quality risk report sorry the court
what what actually what are our big
risks what should we be monitoring which
would give rise in to quarterly risk I
guess that's what I was alluding to yeah
that
um regardless of whether we've got a
finance committee or not and some some
do have that yeah you'd expect
um
the risk associated with the projects
would be part of a finance lens which
would be monthly but maybe quarterly
there'd be some stuff coming through to
this committee that says hey we've got
some serious risk here
um agreed I think we're we're warless on
the same path but it just reflects the
development end of where we're going
Michael I think you've got it coming yes
thank you through yourself chair um in
response to asking about uh Senior
Management
um thoughts and Views in relation to the
process I I support where we we're
heading towards in relation to bringing
in the net risk framework obviously I
think as being the preparer of the
agenda for this whole whole training
pretty much
um it has been about going into the
detail over that time when we didn't
have the risk framework in place
building through where we developed the
risk framework to a point where
hopefully that can start to come in so
exactly the sentiments what the cherish
just expresses exactly what we've been
trying to do and build towards so
hopefully we can bring bring the
reporting to a higher level as soon as
that comes into place and we can take
away some of those more detailed reports
that we have in there at the moment I
know my team will appreciate it if we
start to pull some of those reports out
because I throw a lot of work their way
in relation to this
and we have I think over the course of
this year's brought some summary reports
and rather than multiple detailed
reports so we've started to go down that
journey I think we'll go a bit further
in the next next period thank you
Michael I've got
uh Ross there and then Leslie
the main comment that I think the terms
of reference uh don't need changed I
think it's a reflection of the
governance structure of council over the
past couple of years that is by default
added to this agenda and I think the new
training May well see some change there
thank you Ross Darren I think you're
personally
oh thanks Mr chair um as one of the
councilors who attends this meeting
who's not actually appointed to the
committee I just wanted to comment
um because it was raised that there was
a low return to the survey and I
acknowledge all counselors were given
the opportunity
but my feeling is that counselors who
have never attended this committee
saw no point in responding to the survey
and didn't feel that they were able to
do so and what that actually raises for
me is the importance of this committee
does make me wonder whether it is one of
those committees that all councilors
should be appointed to in the future
but it's just just seemed to me because
the comment was made as though there was
something really bad about
a relatively low response I actually
think councilors who had not attended
this committee who are not appointed to
it
um
probably did not see that they were in a
position to make the response
if you take the thigh of governance and
two of those with Bruce and I that only
leaves three that did respond
hmm
right look I think um uh um without
being
trying to count the numbers at the stage
let's say I your points can I kind of
say is correct
um from my perspective which is how well
how well understood is our work and
that's why amongst other things you'll
see in the recommendations book Brandon
which I think are very good
that um uh that we need to embed risk uh
Management training
um uh generally within the council book
particularly within the council
induction program
it certainly would be a question on the
assumption that we continue with not
with a risk and Assurance committee
which would be my strong recommendation
is why as I say if I can't do that with
a bit of self-interest
um uh look I'll leave it open as to
whether a new committee one of this is a
committee as a whole
um traditionally risk committees are
subcommittee or a smaller grouping of
the total Council
Along supplemented by Independents such
as Ross and myself
um I have also worked with commodities
as a whole so that would be a a
preference of the new Council
would have to consider seriously
did you have your hand up Rome I did but
I think you've answered about 80 of my
question and three or actually it's a
pretty good rule yeah yeah can I sorry
so so with your experience on other
personal Assurance committees the makeup
of them tends to be a subcommittee type
style is that right yeah look it depends
a way but um some are subcommittees of
the finance committee I think that
actually obscures things that we were
personally
um uh to be a committee of council is
actually uh are helpful
um uh but that's just probably as much
personal preference as anything else in
the way it works
um but uh no I you know it's it is
actually probably a case of preference I
mean why do you have communities that
are smaller tend to be for good
efficiency reasons
and amongst other things also
um
uh
where shall I put it
tends to be built like this where you've
got some of the senior members of
council
um that are that that exists then Leslie
thank you for being one of the two or
three that I know that come regularly to
various committees around the country I
appreciate your effort on that but it
tends to be seen as the way to deal with
it but you know committees are the whole
are the other option
thanks
right well I think we take this forward
as as useful information it's given us I
think uh um I'll characterize it as a
ticket of approval um but we're all
acknowledging and we would want the
message that there are developments that
need to occur the big risk strategic
risk approach is obviously one that we
are self acknowledging needs to be
worked on part of which will then give
us a stronger key to what is the the
role that the committee can play going
forward but I also want to just pick up
Leslie's point that we think seriously
about how this committee's work relates
to the governing body as a whole which
makes sense can I move to the
recommendations please I received the
report
and we recommend the fine items for the
consideration in the new trainium to
reference
risk training which includes Council of
the council induction program we
consider the work of the committee we've
discussed that at some length we
continue support management to mature
the approach around the quarterly risk
report
um probably I'd just like to change that
word if I could go over here to
strategic risk management because I
think that's where we want to start from
it would happen quarterly it just have
to be how you do it but it's actually
what we do in the Strategic risk
management please
um and I just need you to scroll down
for me please
um oh no that's it that's the sorry so
it's the last one isn't it so we just if
we're happy to change that to strategic
risk management and Reporting including
a review of the categorization and
contents the reporting linked to the
Financial Risk
um and actually I've got a sorry a third
one if it's okay can we forward this
report to council
Mr chair can I ask and viewers um the
time frame and the trainium do you mean
forward the report to council for its
formal consideration or do you mean
circulate the report to all elected
members uh I'm relaxed I'm making I
suppose to some extent actually when I
think about it my suggested on wasn't on
the cuff sorry but on the um I presume
the recommend the fine items to the new
me it means that it will make its way to
the new mirror and the new Council it
will make it okay in which case forget
number three thank you for the
correction that's good
radio it's my I've moved it so do I have
a secret please
thank you knobby
there's a new discussion on the
motions there aren't I'll put it all
over please say aye thanks those against
Kerry thank you
um
check where we're at I think we're up to
item 12 which is uh actually urgent
business I have been informed of none so
we can go to now the motion to
um exclude public
the public and for the reasons that have
been stated there
um and I just want to check malavika do
we need to pass motion who stays and
doesn't
I think we're okay aren't we we know who
okay I'll move from the chair that for
the reasons that are stated there that
we move into public excluded I have a
second to please
thank you Bix
any discussion on the motion
I'll put it all those in favor please
say
aye those against
it's scary
kind of suggest that we we take a short
break while we get the live streaming
off folk may like may like